hey there everybody time for another
movie retrospective like we do yeah this
one is uh actually was one of the ones
that was in the pile of DVDs that I
showed you guys that I bought at FYE
that they had all the used DVDs and
blu-rays that were like super cheap and
I was really really excited to get my
grubby little mitts on this one because
I've always really really liked this
movie this is the ring from 2002 I'd
never seen it
yeah I actually saw this in the theater
um I'm gonna say obviously uh but most
people probably know this but this is a
remake of a Japanese movie that came out
in 1998 that was called Ringu and this
was actually the first I mean so not
only is this a great movie but it's also
kind of an important movie because this
was the first of the American remakes of
all the Asian films that like there was
a whole flood of them that happened like
after this came out because this one was
so successful you know they did dark
water they did The Grudge they did one
miss called pulse pretty much every
Japanese Chinese Thai horror movie that
had done any sort of business over in
Asia got an American remake this is
easily this was the first one and this
was easily the best one and I'm actually
gonna go I don't know if this is out on
a limb or not but I'm gonna go out on a
limb and say I think this is better than
the Japanese original and I do not say
that lightly
because most of the other ones weren't
dark water was pretty good the woman's
jennifer connelly in it but other than
that the other ones were just did none
of them were as good as the originals
but this one I think was much better so
I saw this in the theater when it first
came out in 2002 and I had I had never
seen the original I saw it later
um this movie scared the [ __ ] out of me
it just it creeped me out so much I was
like thinking about it for like days and
days afterward like weirded out by the
[ __ ] like I think that and I wasn't a
kid I mean I was I think I was 30 when
this came out so I didn't like have an
excuse of being like dated or anything
like that yeah it really [ __ ]
bothered me
like fur I think for a week afterward
which a week that's significant because
of how she goes in the movie but um you
know every time like I passed by a TV
and be like is that [ __ ] gonna come on
and then like they'll be there like this
the little flickering image of the well
on there and I'll be like you know what
I mean it'll be like this horrible yeah
but there is something about this movie
that is just so unsettling there's just
something really really creepy about it
and they don't really make a lot of
movies like that I mean I can count on
one hand I mean I love horror movies and
they don't have to like scare me and
[ __ ] but I can count on one hand the
ones that bothered me so much that I was
still thinking about him like an out
like you know like a week later and was
like totally [ __ ] creeped out by it
so okay so as I said this actually came
out in 2002 it was like a massively
successful film I think they made it for
under 50 mil and it ended up making like
250 million around the world and it was
so successful that it led to like these
remakes of all these other Asian films
and it also led to two sequels The Ring
- which came out in 2005 and then there
was there was a short film that was just
called rings and it was supposed to take
place between the first movie and the
second one
but then in 2017 they made a full-length
movie called rings I haven't seen either
of the sequels but I was watching
something today that had like a bunch of
clips from the sequel from the ring -
and like a guy kind of breaking it down
and talking about it and it sounds like
dumb as hell because it sounds like they
they got Naomi Watts back they got the
kid that played her son back so it had
like it had like big stars I had like
[ __ ] Spacek was in a small role and
stuff but I think they lost a lot of the
magic of the original because they
didn't really it was just more like a
straight-up revenge ghost possession
story whereas the first one had the
urban legend aspect of the you know the
the cursed videotape and stuff like that
and I think they kind of lost that kind
of cool aspect of it in the second one
and it just went in a straightforward
sort of direction plus I think the
second one had like a bunch of life
[ __ ] looking seed CGI so that never
helps but the thing I always liked about
this movie it's all it's not a
particularly gory film it's all about
atmosphere and it's completely and
utterly just drenched in this just
really creepy
eerie kind of atmosphere they filmed it
I don't know if they filmed it in
Seattle but it's supposed to be set in
Seattle it's pretty much raining like
through the whole movie and the whole
movie just has this really like sickly
like Bluegreen kind of cast over it you
know what I mean like it's almost like
it's there's no color in it and it just
has this like kind of pause it's always
very cloudy everything's always wet um
you know it kind of looks like that it
reminded me a little bit what we were
talking about when we were talking about
Dagon about hair everything looks wet
everything looks wet in this movie which
you know it stands to reason because I
think though I think maybe your
appreciation for giallo movies helped
you appreciate this well I really do I
need to see it when it came out yeah and
so I didn't really you know I wasn't
there when it came out yeah so I didn't
really it didn't really make an
impression on me yeah I like you said
it's atmospheric I don't really I get
that sometimes but I had to have a lot
more story elements you know I mean like
it has to be pretty fast-paced for me I
remember not of this I remember this
movie not really keep my attention too
much yeah this one it's actually more
like I mean it's obviously [ __ ] it's
obviously a horror movie but it also has
elements of like a mystery it's like a
detective story because basically what
it is Naomi Watts is the main character
now at the beginning there's these two
teenage girls and they're talking about
the urban legend about this you know
cursed videotape and supposedly you
watch it and then your phone rings and a
voice on the other end of the phone says
seven days like you're gonna die in
seven days and so they're talking about
it and then one of the girls is like
[ __ ] I think I've seen that videotape
that you're talking about it's real and
then they're kind of lay oh no I'm just
kidding of all the blob but then it
turns out she did see it and then she
dyes it in a really really horrible way
and honestly that's really one of the
best scenes this is there's a lot of
great scenes in this movie but one of
the best scenes in this movie that was
so [ __ ] well done there's not like
jump scares or anything like that really
like sometimes it'll kind of cut to like
a really shocking image that you weren't
expecting but it's not you know it's
it's not the same kind of thing where
it's like you're sneaking up on somebody
and like boo you know it's not really
like that
but there's this really great scene
where because Naomi Watts please the
girl who dies um that was her niece so
she's talking to her sister about how
the girl died and her a power mom like
found her in the closet nurse she was
all [ __ ] up and liked us to her face
with all the store didn't stuff and then
suddenly like the film cuts to her and
it's just this horrible like she's just
sitting all the closet in her face she's
just like this horrible horrible and I
think that when I first when I first saw
this in the theater and when I first saw
that saying I'm like oh [ __ ] like you
know I'm a because it looks so so creepy
I think maybe yeah this is the first
movie to kind of do a lot of this kind
of stuff like it like you said yeah and
so many came afterwards that to me it
didn't make the same kind of impression
because it seemed kind of like Sammy
because of all the ones that copy right
yeah so from because I wasn't there at
the time and just it just seemed like to
me just kind of seemed generic well yeah
because this was the first one to do
about seeing it in the context yeah yeah
I mean this was the first one to do the
whole Asian trip because if you were
into Asian horror which a lot of people
weren't like back then it was kind of
like still a real underground thing um
you didn't get the whole that whole
Ouray trope of like you know the the
long-haired the ghosts with the long
black hair and the white dresses that
are like coming out of [ __ ] and light it
moving all weird and stuff it looks like
a Japanese monster from the 70s yeah
like nobody um you know nobody in
mainstream cinema in the United States
had really seen that before so when that
came out so when the ring came out it
was like seemed really fresh and new
that no Chi monster yeah it that's
essentially what it was right so I think
that helps as well but like I said I've
seen some of the other remakes like I've
seen some of the original ones like I
really
like the original grudge which was
called you on the remake was all right
but it wasn't you know anything to write
home about it was a little I just didn't
think it had much to it but like I said
I think this one was way better um
Ringo is good it's just I don't think
it's as scary you know what I mean this
one I think has the strength of this one
all the actors are good they actually
the cursed videotape itself the imagery
on it is way creepier and way more
unsettling than the videotape from the
original movie and I like that they kind
of show it and they don't really give
you any context it's just like all these
are like really really weird
like images you're like what the [ __ ]
does that mean and then like throughout
the course of the movie like I said they
made it almost like a like a psychic
detective story or something like that
where she's trying to figure out where
this tape came from and what these
images are and what they mean um you
know before she dies because she watched
the videotape and she only has seven
days from her creditors like drowned
horses washed up on a seashore wasn't
that Sony yes what else was it it was
like it yeah there was like a woman like
looking over her shoulder in a mirror
there was like a little box that full of
like twitching severed fingers it was
like a you know a little fly there's
like a big horse eyeball yeah there was
all that kind of stuff so it's just and
I love [ __ ] like that because I'm a big
fan of like like old creepy like silent
movies and I love [ __ ] like and actually
the the the videotape in this reminded
me a lot of the movie begotten I don't
know if you guys I've seen that um it
came out in the 90s but he made it look
like an old old like silent film from
the 20s and it's like super nightmarish
and like super disturbing it's just it's
this really horrible like grotty looking
like you know what I mean look it looks
like this really old film and it's sort
of like it doesn't really have like a
story story it's more like a symbolic
type story but just the images on it or
just looks so [ __ ] creepy
that's not stuff on the internet it's
kind of like that look like an old late
1800s or
early 1900s that movie where's guy
walking through the woods and a weird
outfit and there's like nooses and is
that is that the same way I think that
might be actually like about 20 minutes
long um no actually it's a full-length
movie okay so but they might have I mean
people might have taken like pieces of
it there's a there's a very famous image
from begotten of a guy like sitting in a
chair in a corner and like his mouth is
like really big like that yeah yeah and
then like all his like [ __ ]
intestines he's like barfing up his
intestines yeah I didn't like that
that's good that's where I begun and
there's some stuff where it looks like
kinda like evil Greek gods they're all
rotten and stuff too yeah yeah yeah that
it is
yeah it's it's a creepy [ __ ] movie
like I said it's silent there's not
really a plot it's it's it's a symbolic
movie like you know it does make sense
if you kind of like analyze it and see
it a bunch of times like this symbolism
does make sense but it's just I get that
vibe from you know the videotape that
was in the ring it's like it has very
much of that type of thing which i think
is why it creeped me out cuz I'm always
creeped out by just these context lists
images that are like unsettling but you
don't know why you don't know what they
are and [ __ ] like that so yeah so as the
story goes on as I said no Naomi Watts I
don't think she believes at first this
whole urban legend about the tape like I
said her niece died like that and then
she fat finds out that her niece was up
at this like cabin with her friends and
they had all watched the video and not
only had her niece died seven days after
they had been at the cabin and watched
this video but all her other friends had
died too and like these really weird
accidents and they all had these like
weird distorted faces like when they
were found and the doctors couldn't
figure out like what they had died of
exactly so then she's kind of like okay
well maybe there's something to this
she's actually a reporter so her sister
asked her to look to look into it
because she wanted to figure out what
happened to her daughter obviously so
she starts investigating where this tape
came from she goes up to the cabin and
she finds this the videotape like in the
[ __ ]
you know in the lobby or whatever
because they said oh we have all these
tapes and you can watch them in your
cabin or whatever when you're on
vacation and there's one that it's
unmarked and perhaps like a dumbass well
like I said you you wouldn't really
think that the tape is gonna kill you so
she wanted to watch it to see what was
going on so she watches the videotape
phone rings 7-days says a voice over the
phone and she's like [ __ ] me so then so
then like she almost to me now some
people have complained about this but I
this didn't bother me so much she almost
immediately like shows it to her
ex-boyfriend or ex-husband or something
like that because he's like a video
analyst or something like it has some
kind of job like that so she's like what
the [ __ ] is up with this and she said
she shows it to him but they I don't
think he really believes it either
because he's like well I want to see it
she's like what a real owner show to you
but he ends up watching it anyway and so
you know so they have to kind of like
figure out what it is now
the interesting thing is that as the
movie goes on and I said I love [ __ ]
like this because I love the detective
aspect of this because as you're going
through the movie you're finding out
you're seeing like images from the video
like in real life you know what I mean
as and you're finding out like what it
all leads to and the cool thing about it
is that basically what's at the center
of this and I think I talked about this
a little bit on our show that we did on
ted serios like the thought a graffiti
type of thing yeah because that's where
the video tape came from as it turns out
there's this little girl and her name is
Samara she was an adopted girl and she
apparently had the ability to do that
she could put images onto film she can
also put images into people's heads and
the images she was putting in people's
heads were really really horrible so it
turned out that she had been adopted by
this one woman who was infertile and she
had worked on a farm and there were all
these horses that's why there was like
horses in the video and it was her mom
that was in the video too like than the
mirror and stuff but what Samara was
doing was that she was you know like I
said not only putting images into
her mom and her dad and stuff like that
but also in the images of horses when
the horses were like killing themselves
because they were she was like driving
him crazy so um yeah so it turned out
that she had made this videotape like
with her mind essentially it was like
you know images from her mind that she
had projected like onto the film now the
central image of the film the ring and
when you see the poster like the very
famous tagline is before you die you see
the ring which I loved that because it's
like a multi-layered he's like you know
yeah you're watching this movie and
you're gonna die you're watching the
videotape and you're gonna die but also
Samara it turns out was killed by her
mother her mom basically put a bag over
her head and suffocated her so she
thought and threw her down a well and
then pushed the top over the well but
Samara wasn't dead she was down there in
the well for seven days which is why the
curse lasts for seven days and the ring
is the last thing she saw it was the top
of the well over with the with the light
around it like coming and around it now
another cool thing about it and I didn't
even think about this until I was
watching another breakdown of this movie
like earlier today they're like not only
does the ring signify the top of the
well that Samara saw before she died
it also signifies because the only way
that you can save yourself from the
curse is by making a copy of the tape
and so it's a ring in the way that you
have to like pass it to somebody else
and it has to come back like a circle
which that didn't even occur to me and
I'm like oh yeah that's true because
they don't know what ends up happening
Naomi Watts character Rachel
she watched it but she finds out I mean
she goes through and she investigates
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and then
her little kid Aiden watched it - so
then she has like added incentive
because she's like he's gonna die if I
don't figure out what's at the boy if I
don't get to the bottom of this she ends
up finding the well finding out that
Samara was killed by her mother and then
she goes down in the well and finds
Samaras
in there because what you're thinking
and when you're watching the movie
you're thinking this as well that you're
thinking oh well Samara just wanted
somebody to know what happened to her
and and find her and like give her a
proper burial like a normal ghost story
right they like you think that that's
what's gonna solve it like that that's
what the little girl's been trying to
tell everybody so Naomi Watts just like
oh I found her body
big bring samaras body out they give her
a proper burial Naomi Watts doesn't die
so she thinks that she has it all
figured out and then it turns out that
Aidan her son who has kind of been in
some sort of weird like psychic link
with Samara somehow like he keeps
drawing pictures of her and like he
seems to know about her he says to his
mom and there's like horrifying scene
he's like you weren't supposed to help
her like now she's [ __ ] loose because
the thing about it was that all through
the movie you're kind of thinking oh
this poor little girl that was in this
mental hospital and she had this power
and she was like doing this [ __ ] to
people and she couldn't help it but that
wasn't what it was she was an evil
[ __ ] and she was doing that [ __ ]
on purpose because she was evil and her
whole thing was that she wanted people
to make copies of the video to pass
around she wanted everybody to see that
[ __ ] and suffer and die just like she
had suffered and died so she wanted to
like spread the misery so that was kind
of the big twist like at the end because
you think oh they found the body
everything's fine now especially since
Naomi Watts character didn't die after
they did that but then yeah you find out
that wasn't how it rolled and it's funny
because as soon as Naomi Watts character
figures that out she's like oh [ __ ]
her ex-boyfriend had also watched the
video but by the time she gets to his
house he's already [ __ ] up and that's
probably one of the best I mean there's
like I said there's a lot of great
scenes in this movie the one with it
where they first showed the girl at the
beginning like in the closet with her
face all [ __ ] up the scene where the
horse [ __ ] runs off the fairy-like
and he's all like trips off the end of
the ferry and then like he gets all
ground up in the [ __ ] propeller
that's a great scene
and the most iconic scene which turns up
on a lot of like scariest horror movie
lists and stuff like that is where Naomi
Watts his boyfriend Noah is in his thing
and he he had watched the video seven
days before so his TV comes on and he's
like hi wonder why my TV came on it's
like static and stuff
then there's the image of the well
Samara crawls out of the well in the
videotape she gets closer and closer but
she [ __ ] crawls out of the TV and
she's all like flickering and [ __ ] and
she crawls across the floor and she
[ __ ] them all up so yeah it's just like
yeah this is like it's such a such a
good movie and I know like I don't know
I feel like a lot of people when it
first came out I think a lot of people
pissed in moans it's like oh it's not as
good as the original and they messed it
up and [ __ ] but I think in ensuing years
I think people have kind of come down
from that I know that there are some
people that prefer the original and
that's totally fine I like the original
- I just think it wasn't nearly as scary
as this one like I said just the imagery
on the tape wasn't as scary it wasn't
the plot wasn't as cohesive it seemed
like it was a lot more you know not
ambiguous necessarily but it did just do
things together that well miss a
Japanese storytelling doesn't doesn't
always isn't a real cohesive story
well it's they they have a different
structure I noticed
and when particularly when I saw you on
The Grudge and then I saw the remake of
The Grudge and it seemed like when they
did the American remake which I think
had Sarah Michelle Gellar in it if I'm
remembering correctly they tried to do
it like they try to structure it like
the original and you know and I think I
might have mentioned this before but
Western stories we tend to do you know
you know you're kind of like going up to
a climax and then down to a Danny MA you
know it look kind of looks like a not
like a parabola but kind of you know
what I mean just kind of like it's like
a [ __ ] gasps yeah whereas like I feel
like Asian stories are more like
episodic you know what I mean because
particularly The Grudge where it was
kind of like there was this one house
and there was like the little ghosts
away or whatever that noise was any made
and it's sort of like follow
three different families that lived in
this house and kind of the same thing
happened to them but then it started
over and then they did it again so they
have more of like a cyclical type of
narrative thing where we have more like
a rising action falling action at a bar
stuff is all based upon like Shakespeare
yeah exactly it's not got opening acts
and then there's like a complication and
then a resolution you know that's that
constant yes structure yes basically a
beginning a middle and end to ours they
don't really have that no and and yeah I
gotta do is just look at animate and
animate sometimes I'll just drive you
crazy because it's basically like kabuki
really a bunch of people talking in the
middle of a damn storm yeah something's
exploded and then the guy's going to
tell you why his whole motivation and
everything you know tell you this whole
life story before the explosion is
totally engulfed the area you know these
crazy [ __ ] you know time doesn't flow
right in them well I feel like I mean if
you didn't grow up with that expectation
super drums super traumatic and [ __ ] you
know everybody's yelling yeah yeah cuz I
remember going to see The Grudge and
being like okay well like it because it
seemed like oh this little story
happened with this one family I'm like
what that was only like 20 minutes and
then like another family moved into the
house and then it happened same thing
happened again you know what I mean and
they're just like they just showed like
three families I guess the same thing
and I was like yeah it was really weird
because I was like why are we doing this
again this yeah we saw this already but
um that's just south aid till I tell
stories right although I do think I mean
Ringu was not so much like that it did
it's based on a novel so you know it did
kind of have you know a structure to it
that was similar to the American one but
I feel like the American one was just
more you know it just held together more
and it was you know easier to follow it
was a lot more compelling the characters
were a lot more compelling you know it
had that really great atmosphere to it
and you know and it just seemed a lot
creepier to me but you know your your
mileage may vary I'm not sure
now I've I heard
- like I said I haven't seen the
American sequels now the original
Japanese conversion Ringu has had like a
[ __ ] billion sequels I don't even
know and why and they and they have like
you know they have like fights between
the between Samara who I think is called
Sadako over there and like some of the
other girls that are in some of the
other movies like the one in the grudge
versus her engine like that but what I
found out and I'm almost kind of wish
that I didn't know this but in the
sequels to rangu you find out that
Samara the character Samara is actually
only half human that her father is
basically the one video I was like he's
basically kethu because he's like well
cuz he's like a sea demon right which is
why do you get like all the water
imagery and why like when you know like
there's always water like coming out of
the TV and [ __ ] like that like when she
comes out I mean I it didn't really you
didn't really need to go there because
the water thing was explained adequately
in the first movie by the fact that she
died in the bottom of well that was all
full of water so I feel like that was
explained adequately you didn't need to
like keep piling on so there was like
demons and stuff and I like that there
was a supernatural element to the first
one but I just feel like that was going
too far yeah like I said the American
remakes didn't do that but apparently
all of the Japanese remakes the it
either in the second one or the third
one they kind of went in that direction
so she's kind of like not even a person
which I don't think they implied that in
the first one I mean she was adopted and
I don't think they really specified like
where she came from or where she got
those weird powers from that she could
like put creepy images and people's are
why she was so evil and stuff but I
don't think they implied that she was
like a demonic or that she was not human
or anything I don't know but yeah so I
just like I was I heard that today and
I'm like okay I'm kind of glad I don't
watch all the Japanese sequels now cuz
that sounds stupid as hell
but yeah I mean this is easily I mean
easily my favorite of all the Japanese
remakes the one that I think is a lot
better easily one of my favorite horror
movies of the 2000s
you know by quite a large margin so you
know if you haven't seen it I'm sure you
probably have cuz I think pretty much
everyone in the world is probably seeing
it at this point I didn't see it but uh
yeah well it was one that yeah it's it's
kind of like you know I know it'll it
came out in 2002 which I guess was a
long time ago now but I think it's I'm
pretty safe and calling it a horror
classic you know what I mean yeah that's
a long time ago yeah yeah it's
definitely a modern classic yeah so if
you haven't seen it check it out even
though I just boiled everything oh you
told all stories well you know we've
started doing that all these names and
spoiler alert okay well yeah it was a
well made movie you know from what I
remember of it it really didn't pull me
it wasn't my type of story yeah I mean
certain people from certain kind of
movies it just really wasn't my kind of
world it's not like I said it it's one
it's very atmospheric and it's more like
a detective story like a mystery yeah
it's like a mystery with supernatural
elements that has like a real like
atmospheric sort of and like I said and
Naomi Watts is like [ __ ] sensational
I love her she's in you know obviously
she was in Holland really but I can see
how some people might like it yeah and
like I said this is one of the very very
few movies that scared the [ __ ] piss
out of me when I saw it in the theater
it really did it really bothered me like
I was like for several days afterward I
was like creeped up by the [ __ ] idea
of it and I mean that's like a testament
to the director Gore Verbinski he would
later go on to do the Pirates of the
Caribbean movies but to take something
as kind of out there as like an urban
legend about a cursed videotape that'll
kill you if you watch it and actually
kind of made me buy it like I'm kind of
sitting there going I wonder it's like
now I've seen the videotape like in the
movie now I'm gonna die and step into
his [ __ ] so I think they did a really
good job of kind of like doing cuz they
had a really good marketing campaign to
where they would just show the videotape
like the cursed videotape like they
would show it on TV like without saying
what it was you know what I mean so
people would be like what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] it's all these creepy like
little fingers twitch in and [ __ ] like
that but yeah so check it out
if you haven't already and remember if
you liked the show like share subscribe
on all your social media if you would
like to financially support the show we
would really appreciate it and we would
love you forever mash that button mash
that like button mash it mash it Matt is
the southern version you got mash it
yeah you got magic magic magic
down--which fingers yeah
poke it stroke it whatever yeah that
would subscribe ya share and subscribe
like I said if you'd like to financially
support you know patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and the sidebar to a PayPal account if
you'd like to give a one-time donation
remember the movie retrospectives come
out every Friday we also have 13 o'clock
matinee three new movies in the theater
that comes up every Sunday and our
regular episodes come out every Tuesday
so check them out if you haven't already
we will see you next time